le black fait c'est une pratique qui
consiste pour une personne à la peau
blanche de se maquiller en personne
noire une pratique assimilée aujourd'hui
un geste raciste
une connotation que ne connaissent
visiblement pas le comédien gérard
darmon qui sur instagram a publié une
photo de lui la lisant un blackface
photo sur laquelle il s'est glissé dans
le rôle du personnage l'otello de
shakespeare cette explication n'a pas
suffi aux internautes qui ont dénoncé un
dérapage
pardon gérard darmon public sans
pression cette photo sur son instinct
ça va pas la tête face à ces réactions
le comédien a répondu mais de quoi me
parlez-vous avec les blacks fait je suis
un acteur libre en poursuivant qu'il
s'agissait seulement de rendre hommage à
la célèbre pièce de shakespeare
avant de retirer sa publication alors
êtes vous choqué par le black fait de
gérard darmon
alors ça ça fait énormément parler merci
jean messia d'être avec nous il ya tous
les soirs celui-ci 1 voilà merci merci
non et bien merci pour ton invitation et
merci à et gucci berne jean merci merci
d'être là et gucci alors on va rappeler
que vous êtes président fondateur de la
ligue de défense noire africaine et
gucci vous ça forcément ça vous a choqué
ses des riches sidéré vraiment réussi
d'airé vous avez de nombreux appels de
nombreux témoignages de personnes qui
vous ont dit c'est c'est compliqué pour
nous de devoir sade de d'être confronté
à ça oui c'est tous les jours au
quotidien parce que tu étais à des
personnes qui ne sont pas au courant
mais les afrodescendants les personnes
citoyens citoyennes de la communauté
noire en france sont victimes de de
négrophobie tous les jours et la
négrophobie tu es le black fesc
contribuent à nourrir alimenter tout ce
que nous subissons
donc ça nous sidère tous les jours de
voir de telles pratiques en france ça
vous pèse qu'est ce qui se passe dans
votre tête quand vous voyez ça quand il
ya des gens qui vous disent on est on en
a marre d'être présenté comme ça qu'est
ce qu'est ce que ce qu'est ce qui se
passe ce qui se passe c'est que on ne
comprend pas contrairement aux autres
pays en europe dans la france aussi fait
partie de l'onu l'onu condamne
le blackface et qu'en france on arrive
encore à discuter de telles pratiques
en fait il y a des choses sur lesquelles
on ne discute pas mais quand ça concerne
les afrodescendants la communauté noire
on arrive toujours à vouloir trouver une
excuse pour banaliser la souffrance des
noirs pourtant la mémoire est très
importante et la souffrance des noirs il
faut cerner tant que ça compte aussi
autant que la souffrance des juifs des
arméniens d algérie au fait ça doit
rigourd les huits goût accepté d'en
parler il faut comprendre que nous
sommes choqués de voir ce monsieur se
plaindre le corps en noir pour
représenter ou voilà ça ça me choque
alors y'en a qui ne comprennent pas vous
avoir casté maman et moi je comprends
très bien ce que vous avez expliqué mais
dans le cas précis de gérard darmon qui
postent à cette photo parce qu'il va
faire un film
et voilà je pense que je vois pas je
pense que c'est pas du tout dans un but
néfastes pas du tout savons simplement
certain maintenant vous avez raison sur
le tour discours mais il ya ceux qui
font un bac faith sur les tours et non
pour se moquer de la communauté noire ça
c'est un fait qui doivent qu'il faut
condamner dans le cas de darmon je pense
qu'il n'a pas fait a mal et je pense que
dans son cas précis c'est parce que
c'est un acteur et que voilà
othello il trouve que auto et noir et
qui va faire un personnage dans dans
marleau donc je pense sincèrement que
parfois et celle un peu preuve qu'on a
en ce moment sur plein de sujets c'est
que le code le combat est évidemment
nomme vous avez raison sur tout mais on
peut pas toujours il faut ça va être
femme
il me semble parfois il faut savoir
distinguer ce qui est vraiment une
agression et ce qui pour le coup n'a
rien à voir avec une agression parce que
parfois à aller à faire trop de combats
je pense que ça va à l'encontre de votre
combat voilà isabelle morini-bosc où
vous ne comprenez pas oui je comprends
votre combat à vous mais vous faut pas
faire l'amalgamé entre les vrais black
16 et ce qui était une tradition
théâtrale française pendant très
longtemps et lui il est sur un tournage
où il joue le personnage doté look est
tout sauf un personnage qu'on tourne en
dérision et dont il est là on le grime
pour ce rôle et ce point photo comme
tout le monde le fait sur instagram et
il se voit brusquement qualifié d'ultra
raciste et que l'homme le plus
progressiste ou le monde donc je trouve
que le procès est un mauvais procès et
qu'à force de tout confondre on finit
par faire des clivages
la société qui n'a sûrement pas lieu
d'être gilles verdez de choquer vont à
tout va on va laisser un goût de trop
peu près le traitement choqué encore
plus parce que ce que dit benjamin est
ce que vient de dire isabelle réveillant
gérard darmon a fait un acte ou de
provocation mais non et non pas du tout
finie alors ou un acte raciste des
séries aujourd'hui plus personne ni à
londres ni à new york ne se tend en noir
dijon et nantes c'est fini c'est prohibé
dans le monde entier
on ne le faire mais ça c'est vrai que ça
pour ib dans le monde des gens disent
c'est même interdit à aux états unis
c'est un délit connaissons a regretté
moi j'ai juste et gucci d'abord oui on
répondre j'aimerais que le débat ne soit
pas focalisé sur gérard nous ne sommes
pas venus pour parler de gérard ici nous
on parle au nom de la ligue de défense
noire africaine
nous ne disons pas que ce monsieur est
raciste bien sûr mais est-ce que c'est
par carte de sur le fait de se grimer
excusez moi ça rend fou
ça c'est quelque chose qui renforce la
déshumanisation l'humiliation d'accord
qui est pro gt en fait sur les personnes
noires pour jouer un rôle d'othello
africain on n'a pas besoin de se mettre
à la peinture noire sur le corps il y as
suffisamment des comédiens des
enterrements
ah oui d'accord mais est-ce que c'est
peut-être parce que ça coûte trop cher
de les embaucher
ou peut-être que le metteur en scène et
le producteur estime ou estimerait que
ils ne sont pas assez qualifiés n'ont
pas assez de talent pour leur seront à
ce que diégou dessus mais il ya beaucoup
tant qu'ils ont dit je vous le dis oui à
beaucoup de temps qu'ils ont dit on y
pourquoi ils n'ont pas pris un comédien
noir voilà et cécile est content des
mets de gens ont dit sur les réseaux
sociaux ça je suis moche et alors jean
luchaire j'ai une autre question à poser
mais quand omar sy a joué arsène lupin
oui il y avait pas d'acteur blanc
suffisamment talentueux pour jouer
arsène lupin est sûre ça
laissez moi me sur terminer je ne
comprends pas non mais je finis mon
propos je sais je ne comprends pas cette
rage féroce qu'il y a de 2,2 des noirs
et de la diversité de manière générale à
vouloir faire jouer des ddd des
personnages historiques blanc de chez
blanc par des noirs ou par des gens de
la diversité mais lorsque c'est le cas
inverse et bien là on hurle au loup
d'arc désolé moi que moi pour moi c'est
un acteur et mais nous sommes dans un
pays libre
or et je vais vous dire quelque chose
oui on va continuer à se peindre en
blanc en bleu rouge en or entre les
organiser quelque chose
d'accord je me suis je termine ne vont
tout droit que et on va continuer
effectivement à ceux déguisés en indiens
qu'on sulu on a mais ça lui même prend
vahiné on décomptait son put etc
celui ci a laissé sur place ou encore kg
je peux pas finir ma de deux heures vous
racontez les binettes people
on a bien cru que la poutre voilà je dis
juste simple simplement je dis ici nous
sommes dans un pays libre si
effectivement un signe de certaines
communautés trouve qu elles ne sont pas
respectées suffisamment alors que la
france est pourtant l'un des pays sinon
le pays où il ya le plus de tolérance au
monde
on est bien libre à ceux qui sont pas
contents qu'ils nous emmerdent avec leur
complexe et leurs délires j'allais faire
cuire un oeuf et si le blanc de l'oeuf
vous gêne vous avez qu à l'enlever alors
moi juste pour le lait moi je pars du
principe qu'à partir du moment où l'ex
certaines personnes c'est qu'un souci et
en suisse il en est alors un choix en
débat toujours un journaliste de défense
noire africaine n'est pas contre que en
caucasien pu jouer le rôle d'un africain
et vice versa omar sy pour jouer lupin
ne s'est pas mis la peinture sur le
corps
le tricheur si je suis vous avez parlé
je ne sais pas si je suis le
raisonnement de cyril hanouna où il ya
effectivement des gens qui lorsqu'ils
ont vu arsène lupin joué par un noir ont
été vexés chez l'endroit lavalin mais
c'est leur droit
qu'est ce que nous faisons là ce que
nous disons au fait il faut comprendre
que notre couleur de peau n'est pas en
déguisement en venant vous voir ici
la seule chose que je ne pouvais pas
laisser chez moi oui c'est ma couleur de
peau agent peut laisser ma religion avec
vous je peux laisser mes orientations
sexuelles tout mais sauf noir couleur de
alain bouthillier permettez nous reste
de belles je sais mais je suis une
révélation je finissais il faut
comprendre que ce bris mais se met à la
peinture sur le corps
aujourd'hui en france la négrophobie tu
d'accord alors je vais vous poser ces
deux dames attendent et je finis oui je
sais vous n'arrêtez pas de finir je
voudrais aider les gens en france
aujourd'hui on peut traiter des gens de
sale [ __ ] de sale noir sans le
championnant allez j'en ai c'est une
saisie ces questions alisation je vais
vous poser la grèce que nous sommes là
je vais vous n'osez pas parler de je
vais vous poser phobique s'en laisser
imposer votre question est posée une
question vous savez qu'aujourd'hui il y
a énormément de femmes noires qui se
font blanchir la peau c'est d'ailleurs
un véritable business il y en a même qui
rajoute des tresses blondes à leurs
cheveux je n'ai jamais vu des femmes
blanches ou des femmes ou des femmes
blondes sur sauter au plafond
là bas c'est certainement fait de
mauvais choix mais se blanchissent
l'avion bronze alors pourquoi vous
bronzez pourquoi vous à l'eau sur les
n'a rien à voir avec ça alors ça veut
dire oui mais je vais vous dire une
chose merci de merfy d'amour selon free
grèce africaines ne sont pas les
premiers voilà dans le gros de notation
de la peau tout ça et vous avez en main
à la gestion mentale chaud et savez vous
pourquoi ces personnes se d'equipe des
pigments que la peau c'est à cause des
princesses quitté humano mais je vais
vous conter que c'est vous des leaders
qui est pas d'accord et qui dit que cela
choque pas oui en fait là vous dites
faut pas faire le procès de gérard
darmon mai mais en fait en fait tout le
monde se déverse sur lui parce que vous
confondez tout effectivement et gérard
darmon c'est un comédien dont qu'il
rentre dans la peau c'est le cas de le
dire de son personnage et vous savez
bien que quand on est comédien on passe
au maquillage art parfois il faut
rallonger le nid avec des effets des
trucs on met des calvities on rajoute
des cheveux rage de la barre la voie là
on rentre dans la peau d'un personnage
qui a la peau noire et on les met en
noir et il n'y a aucun problème est
justement mère je pense que vous avez
des complexes peut-être à juste titre
parce qu'il ya eu des choses dans
l'histoire mais il faut pas voilà ce
monsieur c'est un acteur c'est un
comédien et le problème en ce moment ça
divise les gens passent il ya trop de
justiciers de antiracisme et du coup ça
divise de trous saml malaise là où il y
en a pas on va passer la dernière partie
de l'émission on très bien merci surtout
jradi de vous ça vous a choqué oui alors
moi ça m'a choqué et d'ailleurs j'ai
évolué mais là tu dois dire j'ai eu
c'est vrai que j'ai lu joie prix j'ai
parlé à ma fille aussi
la jeune génération je trouve évolué
peut-être dans le bon sens et c'est vrai
que moi je trouve ça choquant défis
alors je dis pas que gérard évidemment
gérard darmon verra si je ne dis même
pas que ceux qui ne sont pas choqués
sont racistes
évidemment que non mais je pense que ça
fait quand même écho pardon de blackface
à une pratique qui n'est pas monsieur
jean messia uniquement américaine où il
y avait aussi du blackface n'ont pas dit
non non vous devriez lire qui avait
aussi du black fait dans le vaudeville
français oui tout à fait mais cette
année ça sera sûrement le juger selon
avaaz unis les interdictions peut plus
rien faire mais pas du tout donc avait
donc des acheteurs français qui se
grimer en noir qui considérait comme un
vieux monsieur est un maquillage et il
considérait les noirs comme des sortes
de choses
ridicule grotesque qui était juste bons
à rire mais attendez quand rapport
du coup bien blanc c'est quoi ce
blasphème qui soit entre guillemets
drôle ou pas drôle sérieux ou pas
sérieux ça fait référence à une pratique
qui visent à humilier à se mépriser noir
à partir de là il ne faut pas le faire
parce que je comprends pas c'est à quel
moment la production de cette série mais
accepte ça sur une série qui est diffusé
mais à quel moment ils se disent pas
qu'ils vont se faire défoncer en faisant
ça franchement il ya ici regardez moi ce
qui m'a choqué par contre dans le
déversement de haine parce qu'il y en a
eu sur gérard darmon et bien il ya eu
effectivement plein de commentaires
antisémites alors je sais que vous ça
vous pose pas de problème mais moi ça
merci c'est trop ça du projet j'ai une
vidéo sur nous à puce et à des policiers
devant une manifestation il leur dit
devant la communauté juive vous écartez
les fesses mais alors le cri vous vous
aplatissez mais voilà le genre de propos
que tient la mer a tant parlé du plateau
est ce que vous gérard gérard nous
conduisent sénat confiance et où nous
détruire et sert la chambre sur lantus
et amis tout bon d'ajouter les journées
oui on est on est pas des antisémites
mais s'il joue dans la mort qu'il ya une
partie qui n'y va l'aise en disant que
nous sommes
comment dire que limite quand on en
entend les gens et tout ce que nous
lisons limites en israël en egypte etc
mais je vais vous dire une chose et non
celle que vous dites est pas là
aujourd'hui les brûler
vous venez de jijel sont donc messieurs
le sien sa mort est ce que j'en ai assez
calme aujourd'hui que ce monsieur
d'accord demain que moi je pusse me
déguisée en déporté juif ou un banquier
jeunesse et lille a pas une erreur c'est
pas des noms mais je suis en train de
vous poser la question parce que c'est
très embêtant est juif c'est sensé que
vous comprenez il faut respecter cela
c'est tout ce qu'on demandait nous on
n'est pas venu si la menace n'est
demandée pour chaque chose
donc on vous nous traitez de
suprémacistes loi et vous dit qu'on est
con relaxer tête on peut pas regarder
non mais regardez aussi au plan d'al on
a réussi à huy à 17%
non à 80 3% puis d'avant oui voilà donc
les français restent sages
merci lui il a toujours les sondages à
l'appui sa femme on a bien dû 7 millions
de téléspectateurs de tout à fait le
même
mais mes chéris pour finir il ya une une
fille africaine qui vient d'être tué en
arabie saoudite ont égorgés parce que
africaine parce que noir
voilà vous comprenez aller en arabie
saoudite selon et on en compte doléances
à leurs fans là et à cause de coire que
elle vient de le dire ça continue parce
que on réduit toujours et l'arabie
saoudite jour monsieur guéant vous vous
dénoncez cela aide mais attendez vous
aurez le sénat juste sinon on dans ce
collège est inutilement
c'est mon honneur simpson